[Musique]
compose des chansons depuis déjà 40 ans
et nous avons demandé au robot de chat
GPT décrire des paroles dans le style du
créateur de sauver mon âme
[Musique]
je chante pour ne pas oublier les gens
et les lieux que j'ai aimé
c'est comme pas mauvais c'est pas bon en
même temps c'est c'est le pion voit que
derrière ça une machine qui a analysé
des textes quand on attacher de presse
m'a envoyé ça j'ai lu le texte puis ma
réponse a été je verse des larmes de
métal
les larmes de métal c'était en 1983 mais
en 2023 le phénomène sur Internet les
robots et leur intelligence artificielle
qui créent sur demande des textes ou des
images il y a entre autres le chat GPT
ou encore le nouveau board de Google ils
peuvent produire des œuvres d'art en
quelques secondes Olivier Blais et
spécialiste en intelligence artificielle
on peut générer de la musique qu'on peut
générer des images qui partent de nulle
part si vraiment de la nouveauté qui est
générée à chaque fois qu'on pose des
questions et ça c'est quelque chose qui
plaît particulièrement à l'humain est-ce
que c'est l'intelligence artificielle
que créer l'oeuvre ou c'est quelqu'un
qui a créé une oeuvre à l'aide de
l'intelligence artificielle ça c'est une
très bonne question
dans des films Terminator le robot T800
est puissant mais a-t-il assez de
muscles pour remplacer les artistes le
robot d'aujourd'hui se nourrit
d'informations amassées sur Internet des
informations qu'il digèrent pour faire
une œuvre on est au début de quelque
chose qui va continuer de gagner en
emploi donc parce que les ingrédients
sont là la technologie et arrive à
maturité et s'améliore les artistes ce
sont des créateurs de génie je ne pense
pas qu'on pourra aller remplacer mais je
pense qu'ils vont s'adapter avec cette
nouvelle réalité
à New York le Museum of mother heart
présente jusqu'en mars une machine qui
rêve et qui crée des oeuvres d'art à
partir de la collection du moment mais
encore là derrière cette installation ce
sont des humains qui ont programmé la
bête on n'est pas l'étape ou la machine
va innover ou à la machine comme je vois
insuffler une intention ou quelque chose
la question c'est tiens on s'entend que
le public visé va être l'humain il va
falloir que de l'humain dans la machine
va faire il suffit de l'humanité à ça
pour que ça vienne nous chercher dans
les émotions ça nous parle qu'on en
apprenne sur nous-mêmes
tant de choses que vous human ne
pourriez pas croire dans le film Blade
Runner c'est Android pleure sous la
pluie et il s'approche d'être humain
j'ai pété n'a pas d'émotion mais il peut
être source d'inspiration c'est vraiment
un très bon outil pour faire un
brouillon pour te faire pour te faire
conseiller on va pas remplacer l'artiste
on va pas remplacer le journaliste on va
l'augmenter pour ajouter un peu d'armes
à l'intelligence artificielle nous avons
demandé à Luc de la Rochelière de
composer de la musique sur le texte que
chaque GPT a écrit dans son style voici
donc la toute première chanson composée
en tandem par chat GPT et Luc de la
Rochelière sur montrer ça à quelqu'un
puis que la personne dirait ah oui ça
c'est vraiment du luxe de la Rochelière
ça serait un peu décevant pour moi de
tous les hommes qui m'ont aimer
je chante pour ne pas oublier
les gens les lieux que j'ai aimé
[Musique]
que je pourrais continuer
mais je ne le ferai pas
Montréal